greasy said that's part of the reason
why and that being allen's statistics
from the first game part of the reason
why bill belichick told us this week he
wasn't buying into the josh allen mvp
craze because he didn't see it in that
first game we took care of him in that
game
belichick was asked about it after the
game specifically asked about what the
espn crew said as it relates to the uh
the the belichick dismissing the josh
allen mvp craze
and belichick said
i don't know what they said
i'm on the record on that
and look you're always on the record at
a press conference chris when he added
i'm on the record on that that is his
way of pointing out
that what you say in these production
meetings
is almost all the time off the record
unless they say you can talk about this
you assume you can't
and the fact that they did and this
happened remember earlier in the year
with nick foles and matt nagy and there
was some stuff they said and it created
a brouhaha
they better get these guys up to speed
on what can and can't be said
as a result of these production meetings
because my guess is bill belichick
although he's always mad about pretty
much anything and everything he has
reason to be upset about this if he was
conveying his views within the confines
of this off the record discussion and he
gets attributed to him in a way that's
going to make josh allen motivated to
beat the patriots butts
every time he plays the patriots twice
per year for the remainder of his career
yeah well yeah there's a there's a code
of conduct i think that's the that's the
biggest thing and you know again
you you know it's it's there's
conversations you're talking football we
know all that but i think a statement
that like bill belichick is trying to
say there is yeah that's one you usually
don't pass along on the telecast you
know hey belichick feels good about what
they did against josh allen the first
time around they did a good job bottling
them up i don't think yes bill wanted
that quote
itself being thrown out there that he
doesn't buy into the hype or all of
those things yeah he sees it a little
differently because you know of course
he's going by what he saw with his eye
in person and the in-person test didn't
pass it for him the first time around
might be different now but yeah that's
where as an announcer and i've announced
a handful of games back in the day too
where you you got to go back in your
room at the end of the night and go okay
wait i wrote this down how can i say
this without saying this how can i do
this without attributing this to someone
who actually told me and those type of
things and yeah unfortunately uh for
bill in this case his his dirty laundry
got aired out a little bit
sometimes you got to step on that third
rail a few times to realize you need to
avoid it but uh
uh yeah i look i i just i'm i'm
i'm surprised that this is happening and
somebody needs to explain
and and i like i don't want to be overly
critical but it's but it happened it's
out there when they asked belichick
about it and he says i'm on the record
on that that is the clue to all of us
that whatever he said was not on the
record well i you're right exactly and i
read it almost differently you know i'd
like to see the actual clip and but but
when i read it i wanted i almost felt
like he was like he was going like
i'm on the record with that like they're
like like almost like
i'm on the record for saying that about
josh allen like basically i thought it
was almost like an ask like that way i
think i think he i think that he i
haven't seen the delivery the way that
it was prepared by the patriots there's
no question mark
it's i don't know what they said i'm on
the record on that and i in the context
of the transcript makes sense my
conclusion is and i believe this is
accurate is that he said
um
i i'm on the record on this that i don't
know what they said right meaning i
wasn't on the record with whatever i
said yeah uh to them and uh that that i
think is where
things get a little bit antsy and a
little bit awkward and
the damage is done
because
i and who knows are we gonna remember
this when the bills and the patriots
play next year there's a chance we will
there's a greater chance we won't
but someone is going to remember it
somebody's going to dust it off somebody
who covers the bills is going to ask
josh allen about it some way somehow
it's going to motivate how would it not
would it not motivate you
if you knew if if you knew you had to
play the mastermind of coaches twice a
year
and someone reminded you that he doesn't
think that you're as good as everyone
else does or as good as you really are
isn't that going to give you some extra
motivation as you're getting ready to
play definitely no doubt about it yes
i'm thinking about it all week thinking
about it as i throw a touchdown pass you
know thinking about i want to look over
there and tell him to shove it right now
yeah that's that's the kind of crap that
football players love you know to have
that you know in their brain just a
little bit of extra motivation and and
you can hold that type of grudge for for
a while you know certainly you can bring
it into next year and make it personal
that way uh bill is not a guy that likes
to make those kind of comments be known
we know that he's the master that way
and any you know coach coaches in those
type of meetings all the time say things
like oh he can't play at that position
or that guy's not as good as everybody
says you know that's where when you're
in the business of covering a game you
just you got to know like he's saying
that for me not to air that out like
that's a good tidbit okay maybe that guy
isn't as good as i thought maybe you can
go back and watch what he said there
that makes sense but you don't say it as
in like he told me that he doesn't think
that guy's good anymore
that's a no-no
it's a dangerous game though because
what bill belichick was trying to do if
he said what he said and again greasy
said it twice
if he said what he said he's trying to
influence the narrative that's going to
be attributed to greasy not to belichick
it's genius
but it's also fraught with peril because
there's a chance that the guy you say it
to is going to say you're the one who
said it which is exactly what happened
so it kind of blew up in belichick's
face but he was trying to use you know
the force of personality the bill
belichick reputation i'm going to load
these guys up with stuff that they're
going to go say
and it's going to help create this idea
that what's the big deal with josh allen
right so it's
it's it's genius if it works if it
doesn't then then somebody's scraping up
some toothpaste and trying to put it
back in the tube uh that's greasy for
now but the reality is it could stick to
belichick and the patriots when they
face the bills next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports